The Riddler is one of the most famous villains
in all of comic book history, second perhaps
only to the Joker.
Since first appearing in an October 1948 issue
of "Detective Comics," Edward E. Nygma [NIGG-mah]
has continuously proven to be one of Batman's
most challenging foes.
Known for his love of crime, drama, and, of
course, one singularly puzzling punctuation
mark, the Riddler has appeared in nearly as
many mediums as the Batman himself.
In addition to his long history in the comic
books, the Riddler has also made a number
of memorable appearances in animated form.
Most animated Riddler fans are likely familiar
with John Glover's iteration of the character
from 1992's "Batman: The Animated Series,"
but Glover's animated version of the character
is actually only one of many.
The first animated Riddler appeared in a 1968
CBS TV series titled "The Batman/Superman
Hour."
In his first animated incarnation, the famous
villain is voiced by actor Ted Knight, and
since the Riddler's debut in animation, he
has been voiced by no less than 14 different
actors.
Of course, most people are probably more familiar
with the various live-action adaptations of
the character.
In the 1960s, Nygma was played by two actors.
"The Addams Family" star John Astin played
the character in the second season of Adam
West's "Batman" TV series.
However, the actor who arguably made the character
famous was Frank Gorshin, whose portrayal
of the character in seasons 1 and 3 of the
show is still considered one of the best versions
of the character ever.
Gorshin's Riddler was so beloved by audiences
and critics that the actor was nominated for
an Emmy, a first for the "Batman" franchise.
Gorshin would also go on to reprise his role
as the Riddler in the 1966 film of the same
name, and in the years since, the Riddler's
fame has only grown.
Many millennials probably first came to know
the character as a result of Jim Carrey's
role in 1995's "Batman Forever."
Though that film isn't beloved by many, Carrey's
campy performance is often noted as a highlight
of the movie.
[Batman forever.
1:32:49 until 1:32:53..
"Now that's impressive."
does a thing.]
Modern TV audiences may be more familiar with
Cory Michael Smith's take on Nygma from the
2014 Fox series "Gotham."
Matt Reeves' "The Batman" is also set to tackle
a new incarnation of the infamous character.
According to a recent interview with Reeves,
this version of the Riddler is actually named
Edward Nashton and is loosely based on the
Zodiac Killer.
So, who is the next actor set to bring him
to life?
Emmy Award-nominated actor Paul Dano [DANE-oh]
will portray the infamous villain in Robert
Pattinson's first outing as the Caped Crusader.
Since Dano's casting was first announced in
October 2019, Dano has maintained the usual
vow of silence against spoilers, but he's
also been willing to offer a few teases about
his unique take on the character.
In a recent interview with Empire Magazine,
Dano called his costume "intense" and "powerful."
If you recognize Dano, that's because he's
been a working actor since the late 1990s.
In fact, Dano's relationship with Warner Bros.
goes all the way back to his first on-screen
appearance in a 1998 episode of "Smart Guy."
In the early years of his career, Dano established
himself with a handful of small roles, including
two minor appearances on "The Sopranos."
While Dano has worked on a few television
series, including an Emmy-nomina ted role
on Showtime's "Escape at Dannemora" [dan-uh-MOR-uh],
the majority of the actor's work has been
on the big screen.
Many audiences first became aware of Dano
for his role in 2006's "Little Miss Sunshine,"
but his portrayal of Paul and Eli Sunday in
2007's "There Will Be Blood" may have been
what rocketed the young actor to the A-list.
For his work in the film, Dano was nominated
for a BAFTA Award for Best Supporting Actor.
In the years since, Dano has also appeared
in movies as varied as "Prisoners," "Love
and Mercy," and "Swiss Army Man."
You can get a full look at Dano's Riddler
when "The Batman" hits theaters on March 4.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.